oh wait oh hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to the resident
evil seventies err I didn't know who's
gonna start this soon
I literally just loaded hi friend how
are you doing are you here to kill me or
am I here to kill you
I don't really know considering the
cameras pointed at me unless I'm filming
a challenge video to see who gets
stabbed first challenge thank you for
destroying my camera soldiers only
really expensive so yeah hi hi everybody
I was not prepared for this I was
expecting there to be a title screen and
then I I'm just filled with questions
why he thank you excuse me thank you for
that still okay I got him still
I'm literally tied to a chair for oh
geez oh oh okay here we go this is what
I was hoping for so welcome to the
Resident Evil 7 teaser now this game um
it was released a few days ago or not
the game the teaser itself is just a
demo and it was released a few days ago
um and it's really interesting because
it's just a teaser and a lot of people
been comparing it to PT and I'll save
judgment for that until later but it's
supposed to bring Resident Evil into a
different light cuz as many of you may
know ever since Resident Evil 4 it's
turned more into an action game and it
seems oh get out of the house well
that's not all - thank you I'll get out
in my own time please don't pressure me
wool okay left to walk I'm
now I'm playing oh hi who are you oh
geez look at the stare on that guy holy
[ __ ] oh man
you think he was getting his soul sucked
out instead of just a picture taken all
righty then
hello hi Oh what lovely TV I don't I
don't have videotape but apparently
someone in this house wants to murder me
oh boy
Bing bong Bing Nene oh [ __ ]
why did that happen who did that
alrighty then oh boy a Foose box danger
why so the stairs fuse is missing I
didn't even know that that could be a
fuse sorry
whenever I get loaded up into it okay
that doesn't scare me I've been through
worse than that you're gonna have to
live up to a lot if you want to get to
PT levels of scary uh-huh
that's what I thought oh that's kind of
cool hi Hey closing doors Oh boohoo so
scary all right what do we got can I see
myself no is there something behind me
no hi oh that's not good oh that's not
good at all but someone has an artistic
side apparently
okay so there's like some sort of
boarded up door here which is always a
good sign when you're waking up in a
strange place and I don't really know
why I'm here do
Oh Oh go good-o
grain a dummy finger okay check
inventory hi part of a dummy's hand made
of celluloid whoo celluloid whoo-hoo
upstairs I don't like the look at that
here we go
I'm bolding and oh uh hi are you doing
are you doing what the [ __ ] was that
okay
stairs quick huh it did nothing good
geez did one of you miss a finger huh
you [ __ ] ah god damn why did I touch
the boob it's just a mannequin boob
character guy don't be so desperate
about it
jeez Oh dad Oh Gersh oh hi how are you
doing oh that's cool
that's gross hey wait a minute you were
there before you didn't exist before oh
they're gonna be one of those games I
haven't played it um a mannequin game in
a long time it's an underutilized thing
nowadays people don't really do it
anymore
still freaks the hell out of me okay so
that was was that oh that was that okay
ready then okay jeez all right um well
looks like I just missed dinner that's a
shame I was a mite bit peckish
Oh at least there's spaghetti among the
maggots hi
who the [ __ ] do you do oh hey
Oh Oh what is that that a crow
oof you know nothing cruel you
especially know nothing considering
you're dead oh geez oh yeah girls get up
me well so far so it's like moderate
spook egde it's not a whole lot of spook
it's going on here
small keyhole huh okay so I need a key
for that that's good I can't open that
one
can I crouch me whoopee okay I can run a
bit that's nice
ah the ominous door at the end of a
hallway always a good sign in a horror
game well nothing's happened yet so
bring it on oh [ __ ] I didn't mean to go
in this room this room looks like a bad
room oh I've been to many rooms in my
day oh jeez what are these these like
the halves of cows why are they here oh
hello meet her Oh
bolt cutters ah handy what the [ __ ] was
that I didn't even see it
oh jeez hi what the [ __ ] are you what
are you a baby Lisa's baby isn't talking
the [ __ ] was that behind me how many
times have I said the [ __ ] was that in
this game so much [ __ ] happening all
around me right oh this was a bull [ __ ]
you
alright ok it's getting moderately
spooky in here okay I got you I can put
two and two together pick my superior
mind nose oh what's gonna pop out of me
wink Oh Oh God oh good great great I
want to see this is probably good
probably not someone being murdered oh
geez
good jeez there's a lot more sounds
happening and I'm not too keen on it
okay so I gotta find a place to get the
key for that obviously I couldn't just
use my bolt cutters to do it that would
be too logical and I'm not full of logic
okay time to skedaddle cuz I know spooks
oh wait maybe that sounded less like a
dog and more like a guy doing a snarling
impression whoo that probably wasn't
good
hey Andy you guys seen a key all right
let's be on my way then
I gotta oh no hey ya slap your meaty
hand on that
oh oh I thought that was the growling oh
okay now what happened here
thank you you're so so good about that
okay fine
it's whatever that spooky not at all
- but you're not scary I'm not afraid of
you your death stare okay
I think here my superior intellect is
telling me these go together just like
this this is where the girls oh hey oh
boy derelict house June 1 del V haunted
house rehearsal great cool
what does that mean oh god damn it [ __ ]
you dude hey guy
give me a break peace hey I only work
with professionals speaking of which
make sure the sound is right this time I
don't want to repeat of Amarillo uh-huh
two [ __ ] years ago
I don't do ADR oh oh oh I'm playing not
feeling it oh no be surprised if we have
to make a change or jeez why am I in
control of the past this is not the best
site first wool oh shoot the interim bar
just like we always do
just look try to say the show's name
this time okay uh-huh
no problem wait for me oh geez another
worthless [ __ ] [ __ ] happy sorry I'm
sorry guys I wasn't paying attention
what they were talking about I was
distracted okay cool
what are we doing we filming a TV show
cool cool
are we rolling yeah let's go okay get
out of the way yeah loser time for a man
to do this lot like that see manly
thanks you bruh after me no after all
come on man
so we'll be like that why are we and
hold this time do you ever press what's
the prep shitty house goopy sound
who is it haunted oh it's the house
whirring okay I get it I get it I was an
anchor you know we can sub Pete not
anchor what's that
nothing oh geez hi hello back of that
guy whose name was just said story on a
modern farmhouse missing family foul
play suspected the usual
huh how long do you say this place has
been abandoned three years fancy get a
shot of this is that mine at away you
got it Lewis
hillbilly Jonah's family go missing not
hillbillies the baker's jack and
Marguerite Baker no bugs is done they
were quiet not backward a lot of bad
rumors about their son Lucas bad seed
apparently [ __ ]
ha ha I know I shouldn't wear my good
shoes jeez oh yeah why can't I walk here
at my shots hey wait a minute
why can't I work here after op huh ah
Dre what do you think I know oh I get it
Andra I see Andre Andre Roger went no
not at all I just saw the invisible wall
that meant we were gonna get separated
I'm [ __ ] believable I know right it's
the last time I work with that guy
uh-huh I mean producers they come and go
but a good cameraman like you Clancy you
slicker all right cool thank you you're
so nice and kind I love you we're
probably gonna die oh the dolls aren't
there anymore
okay what was that did you hear that
no I was just listening to the sounds of
music across and shut up [ __ ] [ __ ]
you I'm not even interested enough in
being sarcastic at you the [ __ ] is he
I don't know why would why would he even
be behind the closed doors why would he
be in the bachelors mess how do you've
gotten there
I mean obviously the answer someone took
him took him away is he gonna get sucked
up in there oh he's gonna get sucked
what the hell oh okay
ah New Deal we we find Andre and we go I
mean [ __ ] this show okay
or we could just leave now that's an
option I'm not really emotionally
attached one way or another - Andre why
are you going in the murder hole this is
clearly a murder hole why would you walk
in the murder and how would Andre get
back here it's all highly illogical I've
got a lot of experience in horror games
oh great oh this is wonderful
oh this is delightful you first I was
already going hurry about me coming down
the ladder huh yeah sure will do first
okay great
don't mind me as I run up into death
alone scared oh uh oh oh geez oh oh this
is so the ring or not the ring this so
Blair Witch Project oh man why is he
hanging on his tippy toes is he hanging
by something is he hanging by a meat
hook whoa I don't like that can I go
back up now what is it uh what happens
if I just go back up you don't want to
go down there man it's bad news man
let's get the [ __ ] out of here bruh dude
are you kidding me don't go down there
ah fine what am i a baby alright
I'll confront it maybe he's just fine
and everything is 100% a-okay
perfect not a okay understand not a okay
Andre Clancy and whatever the hell that
guy's name is oh god damn it
oh and there's a meaty wall what is
what are you do hello hi yeah just lay
on my lap for a little bit it'll be okay
oh hi hi oh you you a now okay
oh hello hi I shall - you against the
stones
well isn't that lovely thank you
that means so much to me to know you
care all right
oh wait oh I don't know what that is
it looks like Oh looks like a face with
really full lips luscious lips I don't
know maybe I see a pair of boobs I'm not
sure what that says about me but I guess
our pair of boobs okay well at least now
I know where the thing is so maybe I'll
find something so if I go down here
ah-ha hello I wonder what would happen
what would happen if I'd uh if I to play
this again and I go straight for that
what would happen cuz obviously it's
there
so I know about it yeah into the murder
hole we go I'm sure this will turn out
better for me
well Oh backdoor key handy that okey
dokey geez I can't go down there but I
want to go down so badly oh it looks so
much fun down there people's heads being
rammed onto pipes and [ __ ]
great grave huh okay alright okay
alright
okay did the murderer fall down and
break his hip Oh was that there I don't
recall that being there whoo
why does grandma have a bag over her
head hey Oh friend is gone
where did friend go I wonder where oh
geez why did friend disappear friend
where did friend go oh geez oh geez okay
alrighty then
it can't be so easy that I walk out the
back door I know for a fact that's not
gonna happen
fact whoo hey oh god damn it where did
you come from
hey friend welcome back who threw you
did you fall or joyous day oh joy is d
alrighty then
okey-dokey well here we go onwards to
victory this is gonna go great yeah
dummy finger wink
looky here we go jeez some of the family
oh hi is that the guy from the painting
probably Oh hurry the freaking up dude
would you drop it oh I don't see it I
hear ya no joke
maybe you wanna oh that's not good
Oh what's that it I come to bed
ah open the door to the Resident Evil
ambassador program what does that mean
what the frig does and mean what the
hell's of Resident Evil Ambassador
Program this is [ __ ] what the Frick
I can't have been in what okay hang on
I'm gonna go back in because I want to
know who Hey I wanna know
I bet though there must be a reason why
people are comparing this to PT because
I picked up like there was a lot of
things that I didn't do I didn't open
the drawer I got that finger I probably
should have used it on one of the
dummies or something I have no idea but
if I go right over here
and go right there I am what does that
do
does it break the goddamn game I bet it
do oh [ __ ] I don't sound good hello ha
ha ha I'm beating your system bruh
beating your system hello
oh [ __ ] dude I wonder why that got there
then and not before ah
because there are secrets in the game
that need to be explored so if I put
this fuse in the fuse box like that and
then it's labeled stairs there's a
button for stairs upstairs and if I
press that what the hell does it do
ah yes these are all good mysteries
y'all excellent I'm not scared of you
nothing gonna happen I know my fears and
you're not part of them I'm marching off
into the distance I'm gonna pick up this
goddamn finger I'm gonna figure it the
[ __ ] out alright Hey Oh examine hello hi
what the hell hi I'll be with you in a
moment
oof you you did it maybe I need to point
at the thing in the universe ooh what is
that it's a tacky who is that something
that's something it looked like there
was like a key in the back
I could throw it away no fan can throw
it away all right fine then ah yes good
hello welcome to the party we've got a
secret to explore okay [ __ ] oh [ __ ] whoa
hey Wow
cool oh hi oh jeez hello cool
you guys want a finger you want a finger
huh not a finger Hey okay bye then I'll
be uh I'll be up here where there's
stuff in things yeah
phone guy somehow I always do oh geez
man let me see everything first
whoa that don't look friendly that don't
look friendly at all well [ __ ] no that's
gonna do for me okay right hello oh jeez
okay fine okay right oh hi hello how are
you doing okay
you gonna do something to me hmm
what's with the ah it's the umbrella
corporation okay ah hello are they
watching us from that helicopter is who
watching us the government government oh
hello hello I know who you are oh lordy
you have the power to choose the outcome
with that choice may not be what you
expect mm-hmm
okay what does that mean what does it
mean what choice what choice do I have
I don't know that's no good eh Owen and
talk to anybody they call a number [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ]
maybe then so ah that means he's gotta
come to the family
Wow [ __ ] where did you come from what
the [ __ ] are you kidding me what let
make any goddamn sense where the [ __ ]
did he come from what
what the hell we gotta get out of here
okay so apparently apparently that is
how that's supposed to end the guy just
ambushes you after you answer the phone
and it doesn't seem like anyone knows
what the finger does it's weird that's
weird
okay so there's only one other thing in
here that it seems like it wants me to
see ah so we're gonna find out what it
is
and what I'm gonna do is I'm going to do
some things here it's gonna be Totally
Rad and you guys are gonna see what but
there's an axe that you can get but
people don't know what the purpose is
you can swing it around a whole bunch
but really doesn't seem to do much so
I'm actually gonna try a few things here
I'm gonna open this up I'm gonna get the
stairs and I'm gonna go get the phone
ringing and then I'm gonna go get the
axe and see if I can progress the story
any further that way that would be a
drink did I even grab the key oh there
is no key okay that's interesting
so there's no key their owner if I've
doomed myself yeah welcome forget it ah
ah oh hey okay so lockpick then you go
over here do this thing you pick this
lock and apparently there'll be nothing
in it right now but in the future it'll
be unlocked for so losing [ __ ] reason
I'm [ __ ] believable odd [ __ ]
believable I know might work with that
guy I know right alright so now we grab
the key if we want to I doesn't really
matter I guess at this point but now
that we've got all that done well well
what the [ __ ] what the
that was the guy
folks EURion anybody gonna get there
what the [ __ ] Jesus what's going on up
there
I'm gonna go explore that in a second
but in here right around here there
should be AI ha any action I can attack
with it I don't know people said there's
no use to it I don't know let me go up
and explore the upper area there's a
crash and a bang up here wondering if
someone is you you see anything yeah
yeah ah [ __ ] oh jeez Hey okay oh nice oh
yeah okay I am [ __ ] okay huh yeah hello
tusky husky masses oh holy [ __ ] I didn't
expect that taxi do anything what the
[ __ ] nice legs
huh
fascinating okay so now that I have the
axe um I I really don't know what else
to do its I don't think anybody knows
what else to do I supposedly there's a
way to quote-unquote beat the demo but
no one's been able to you know figure it
out yet something to do with the dummy
finger but I'm not isn't sure no one so
that is all that I know to get right now
so now see their choice of going out the
back door try on the phone call but
either way god damn it that got me
already
MSG ran your booty ah oh oh okay all
right so I'm gonna go the route of the
phone call Dennis I don't think this axe
is gonna help in any way to defeat the
guy but there's a possibility this phone
call might be different so I know you
are now same thing who are you why are
you told the truth don't let appearances
mislead you I'm gonna blow oh that's my
hand I'm gonna back myself into a corner
he'll never be able to get me if I'm in
a corner he can't yo how'd you wait how
are you alive again I smashed you up if
I got my back to the wall he'll never
get me yeah you better get out of the
way oh hello ah I stick up your butt ah
I'm like a wild animal when I'm cornered
no telling what I'll do whoo geez
passion well I don't seem good well he's
gonna get me I have a funny feeling
hello oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ] oh geez oh geez oh
geez
well I mean I'm not dead yet I'm not
dead yet
why am I not dead yet what is this made
wood jeez okay okay oh jeez I don't know
what's going on I'm very confused huh
I seem to have survived but I can't
exactly leave or else I'll just die
again right probably what happens if I
put the key in there and then don't go
out the door huh maybe you're scared of
me maybe he's afraid that's probably it
right okay I am thank you okay
well [ __ ] all right bill okay
enough for you enough for you enough you
okay so that is all for this I don't
know how to get any farther I don't
think anybody knows how to get any
farther but for now this is looking
promising it's not quite as spoopy scary
as Petey was but it's still looking like
it might be pretty good especially
considering it's a departure from normal
resident evil like fleam that they've
had going on so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to check
out Petey the video is available in the
description or in the annotation over
there check it out lots of fun thank you
again and as always I will see you in
the next video